basically just trying to make a tower of
men I got that part but why you know
there's a whole y aspect of it why not
well there's a lot of reasons why not
one it doesn't seem very structurally
sound as an engineer I take great
offense of that too I really only got
that one reason so oh god what am I
doing wrong
oh I get it the mouse oh it drags
towards the mouse so if I yeah oh and
then I like all that and it's like oh
you're and then your penis spins around
it's like a it's like a co-op type thing
hey I got you here wow you're mean l
okay I see how it is I just I copy every
youtuber I see so pretty much no one's
safe from me right so hang on oh wait
why do you have big layers you have
berries for Oh God where did I go I
don't know you got 41 seconds to correct
that mistake you've got a berry penis
look at that it's like a bunch of
blackberries actually you got a buried
penis considering this is in fact you
that's true that's true and it's sad
wildly accurate I'm so good at grabbing
that goats ass you have no idea yeah
your physical basis Tegel berries ah ah
but I can go I can go higher are the
grunting noises necessary to go higher
in this game ah a little bit why are you
elude I'm not a boot I have a boot on my
head Oh
why do you got to be so judgmental about
people with boots on their head I don't
know are you like a humble no I'm not a
hobo why you Dana
hobo is this your last ditch effort to
make a few extra bucks some some rich
man was like why don't you climb a tower
amazed horribly horribly offensive but
that would make sense yeah some rich guy
standing up in the seat in the bleachers
it's just like mmm climb men for Mayans
hyah hyah please okay hey yeah let go
ahead him there you go okay then W are
you I was against I might have an
advantage over you
no you shut your mouth I am experts at
all games that I play so okay you'll
just keep you're gonna see well we're
being a pretty precise tower it's a it's
a stairway to heaven so we have only 60
seconds each single time that we like
god I can't force your brain is like a
is not a button that I would press is
that you don't BRE use the a button no
naps felt like ass no stiff that's gross
God the low gravity thing definitely
makes an effect on you falling off the
Tower of Jonah shut up [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
piece of ass this is impossible it's not
a pot we mill I've made some pretty
impressive that's very possible
damn it no come on time no my dong is
wrote a oh wait why are you on the left
now why am I on the right I have no idea
ah you're screwed now you can't grab the
goats ass what that's true I'll be
devastated it oh okay
very nice as you can see wait a minute
here oh you why are you using my images
you sent me your images I thought that
was the point but you don't put them on
your team why not you just leave them in
the folder that way you can see mine
when I'm when it's my turn oh I didn't
know that why was it that well now you
do next we ax how do you can you can you
can you can fix the sordid mess or
whatever there I am hahahaha ah good
remember what keys okay I'm pressing D
wiesen out there it goes W raise it up
let that okay I'm getting the hang of
this
hit it get it hey of this god oh oh huh
gotcha he'll go a salute to goat face I
know you have trouble differentiating
but well I'm calling him an ass no I
don't think so
nice operate please not he's not a burro
but what a burro a burro like a donkey
an ass oh boo
let's go safe there
thank you I know huh so smashing buttons
randomly is not appreciated in this game
I mean is it appreciated but it
definitely doesn't help your cause yeah
right now that's just a bunch of wigglin
shut up this wiggling is gonna win me
this game okay yet it yet it God I got
it don't tell me what I need to do I am
all over it I'm over it
I feel like I'm grabbing you oh yeah
yeah yeah exactly
grabbing my own ass is exactly what is
gonna win me this game right here Oh why
are we I look like Hercules right now oh
not really not in any way not you look
at look at my loincloth oh goodness I'm
looking right at your loincloth I can't
help but look at your lone cloth and I
can't think of Hercules when I look at
it Hercules her couple lilies I'm just
thinking of the rock is Hercules no I'm
drooling a little bit yeah he is a
perfect man specimen try getting back
there with your grunts and your her
lilies dreams Oh God hello I'm gonna win
I win one I can't even begin to win yeah
grab those grapes
grab those grapes and you lost whoa I
won okay grab right there okay
oh oh okay huh no nope go wrong go wrong
oh there we go there you go you did the
thing oh this is not okay uh-huh
ah that site is so obnoxious to start on
you can't grab on to me I've lubed
myself up she call you empty meatspin I
wish I could you know people have lived
that don't know the glory of that
website I think the whole world should
be showing that as we're here yeah how
can I just stay here through a little
bit come on okay this is gonna be hard
Oh yep okay that's what I'm gonna do
I screwed myself of this angle here okay
yeah way to go deal okay whoa okay so
it's it's all about it's all about the
release okay it's all about the release
sorry they said Oh once again I I really
gotta ask the grunting does it help it
does should I try it it's scientifically
proven to help yes I always push more
but more than one tested mother approved
oh whoa hey whit okay yeah Oh Mary you
hey hey again that's not good
ha okay is it oh the book come on huh
you got 15 seconds I don't my seconds I
guess took the win yeah you're in you're
gonna do gonna make this one round oh
yeah yeah whoa okay woof aah I like the
angle of your dangle I like to dangle of
your angle like the mirth of your girth
wow that was good thank you
I like the Venus of your penis I like
the UH
go higher the strange like the strength
of your length is that don't lose that's
not bad I like the bank in your Wang Oh
oh yeah oh nice yeah we get that bad oh
yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh oh it's
full oh oh yeah beat that one Dixon I'm
gonna try why you need to let me do
things I like oh I like the stick of
your dick that's a woman fool that's not
bad that's up I like the fundal of your
grundle
Oh what is fun to me nothing really
rhymes the grundles wait no bundle
bundle bundle it Wow yeah see there you
go I guess it's hard to concentrate and
try to climb a mountain a man at the
same time oh who knows more eggs
benedict oh yeah